so right your life is that part of the
Travis technique yes it's a part there
are three main elements of the Travis
technique one is right your life which
is the autobiographical storytelling
which is besides telling your own
personal stories it's all the basics of
storytelling all the structural aspects
of telling any kind of story so it
really grounds you in storytelling and
one thing that's important about it is
it's not a writing class per se it's a
story telling can you tell the story
directors writers and actors need to
learn how to tell stories not just write
them writing comes next
can I actually sit down and tell you a
story take three minutes and tell you a
story by him and then can I examine my
own character within the story know my
own character and can I consciously take
you on a journey through that little
three minute story the when you tell an
autobiographical story the goal is if I
were to tell you our biographical story
right now Karen the goal my goal would
be I'm going to tell it take you through
an event now take me three to five
minutes to tell you and my goal is to
have you experience while you're
listening to the story is acts exactly
what I experienced as I lived it without
having to tell you all that at that
point I was really sad and all that I
don't have to fill that Ellen I will
tell this story in such a way that you
get it immediately now that's the power
of storytelling whether it's verbal or
cinema or a play or even a novel to be
able to do this so that's what lights
your life is about is a very powerful
experience this is why a lot of people
take it over and over and over again
they keep coming back and take it again
take it again
it's like going back to the gym and
working out all those muscles of
storytelling again the basics the other
two aspects of the Travis technique the
next one is the interrogation process
which you know about a little bit which
is the directorial technique of working
with act
to access the characters it's a process
of not directing the actors but actually
accessing the characters talking to the
characters and how to stimulate the
characters with the understanding that
when you cast somebody in a movie
basically from my point of view when I
cast somebody I'm saying to that actor
the cat character I want you to play
exists already I will tell the actresses
the character exists already inside you
you do not need to create the character
you do not need to develop the character
you don't need to do anything except
that some one thing that you have to do
which is very very hard to do it's
almost impossible you have to get out of
the way and let the character come out
because the character is inside you
the problem is you're in the way but I
can help you now that's the
interrogation process which helps the
actor actually remove themselves from a
process kind of allow the character to
emerge and we can talk more about that
the third part of the Travis technique
is the power of staging and this all has
to do with very simple concept that is
so powerful that we all deal with every
moment of our lives we all move in the
world and pretty much the same way all
of us we all move around the world
avoiding conflicts seeking comfort even
as we set up to shoot this that's what
we did we we all move in relationship to
the environment and to other people and
even the way we sit and what share we
want we all move that way now this is
how we remove we move in life in
response to all the elements around us
the power of staging is what creating
something artificial so I can stage a
scene in such a way which I could
demonstrate I could stage a scene in
such a way that how I move the actors in
relationship to each other in
relationship to the environment whatever
it is and even in terms of their own
body language I can move them and
actually stimulate within every actor
the emotion I need for the character at
that moment whether it's comfort
discomfort anger rage abandonment
whatever it is I can move them in such a
way that that gets triggered in the
actor and the actor now does not have to
create that feeling the actor has to
know struggle with that feeling as we
move through life all of us
we're impacted and we have emotional
reactions to things we can we feel sad
we feel happy we till abandoned we feel
uncomfortable whatever we have emotional
reactions we don't go through life
trying to create emotions I don't know
of anybody who's ever done that I think
I'm going to be happy in the next second
and I'm innocent you know we don't do
that we would like to have this but we
have these emotional reactions so my
goal and it's very successful working
with staging is I can trigger emotions
inside the actor that are appropriate
for the character and now as the
character they have to struggle with
that emotion what to do with it and now
it's authentic you're not watching an
actor create an emotion or pretend to
have an emotion you'll watch it watching
an actual person struggling with or
embracing whatever they're doing dealing
with genuine emotions and that's the
power of staging and the other aspect of
that it's when it's working well the
audience sees it immediately the
audience will react emotionally to so
I'm actually triggering emotions in the
audience simultaneously as I'm doing it
with the act it's like be again getting
back to what we were talking about
before because of projection because
when we watch a scene when we watch a
movie we like to play we watch anything
even if we watch people in life we
project ourselves into them and we see
two people arguing at another table
oh he's so uncomfortable well why are
you reacting that way because you're
saying if I was there this is how I
would be feeling so through staging I
can trigger emotions in the audience and
get help the audience identify more
deeply with the characters so those are
the three elements so when you're doing
a weekend seminar are you beginning with
the writing portion
and then working in interrogation and
then doing the staging or well it's not
on a weekend that's a great question and
it's something that Elsa and I struggle
with all the time for every workshop we
put together our ideal situation yet we
would deal with all of it but then it's
going to take days or weeks because it's
each one is so massive so what we have
is we have a weekend workshop that we do
frequently which is just called write
your life so you can learn that then we
have other weekend workshops that we've
done or longer which aren't on the
interrogation process that last time we
did that it was actually longer it was
10 days just for directors just to learn
the interrogation process or will
include the interrogation process and
staging together so it's the Travis
Technique is it really an umbrella for a
lot a lot of stuff and we have found if
we try to teach too much in a short
period of time then we're skimming over
the surface and we like to do workshops
where you can really plunge yourself
into one technique one aspect of it to
really benefit from digging that deep
into that process one last question and
then we'll move on in terms of the
writing your life portion what are some
things that you see get in the way of
people telling an authentic version of a
scene from their life I mean do people
tend to paint too rosy of a picture of a
scene that's really from their own life
or the opposite because people tend to
sometimes embellish memories that aren't
they're too traumatic and you can kind
of sense that it's not authentic
yeah well all yeah all of that can
happen and there's more that can happen
first of all we have to look at someone
I mean next time wherever you are you
and David or someplace listening to
friends tell a story just listen and ask
yourself seriously and this is not
critical at all why are they telling the
story why is she telling this story why
is he telling this story you know
there's this an agenda there's a reason
telling the story to to make a point
clear that they were trying to make
earlier and they're using the story to
tell it but fine maybe they're telling
the story for self-aggrandizement maybe
they're telling up her they want
sympathy or pity who know there's a
there's always a reason for telling the
story and this is it's an
autobiographical story lots of times the
reason to tell the story is for you I
want to tell the story so you understand
something about me so I'm doing it for
me I'm trying to elicit something out of
you what we do in right your life is say
can you tell this story and think of the
story as a gift I want to give you a
gift the gift is the experience you're
going to go through hearing the story
has nothing to do with me in a way even
though it's my story because when we
make a film when we tell a story that's
a gift to the world I don't want I make
a movie I don't want people to be
thinking about me the director not at
all I want them involved in the story
the gift and the gift of the story
whether it's told or it's a film the
gift of the story is twofold one is what
the viewer or listener is experiencing
as the story is being on full unfolding
that's one gift those two hours in the
movie or the five minutes it was in a
story that's one gift the other gift
which is even bigger in a way is the
legacy of the story we've all seen
movies that we will never forget we've
all seen movies that have changed our
lives in certain ways and sometimes
we're not even aware of it until years
later we go all of that
Wow it's when I saw that movie something
shift that's the power of what we're
doing and that's also the gift of
storytelling that it can last forever
and again it's not about the storyteller
so getting back to your question what
are the traps they can fall into is are
you doing this so you tell your story so
that the listener will see you in a
different way well that's been it's all
about you and you're doing this for
self-aggrandizement or something else
are you willing this is a big question
and Rachel are you willing to tell the
story
and reveal really how vulnerable you
were how stupid you were how Paragons
you were which means how human you were
at that time can you do that that's not
asking for pity in other words how
honest can you be so what we focus on in
the right your life can you tell it
honestly get the agenda out of the way
your agenda now is be honest and that's
what a lot of people struggle with they
struggle first of all looking at what
was really going on when they start to
see it it gets a little shaky and then
reveal it to get to even shaky and I
said well that's the business were and
we're storytellers and we don't tell
stories for people to change their
opinion about us we actually spell tell
stories so people can have an experience
that may shift something within them and
maybe even change their opinion about
themselves not about us we have to tell
these stories
honestly authentically we the director
writer and actors actually have to this
is really ironic because we are the
primary exclusive I call the golden
triangle director actors or writers
that's the golden triangle that's
telling the story the rest of it is a
support system we as that golden
triangle the primary triangle telling
stories have to get out of the way we
have to remove ourselves from the very
thing we're doing which is very hard
it's not about the writer it's not about
the director and it's certainly not
about the actors it's about the
characters we have to get out of the way
and serve the story and serve the
characters and that's hard
you